Awesome are ridiculous and unbelievably small.
A single human hair is about as thick as 500,000 carbon atoms stacked over each
other.
Look at your fist.
It contains trillions and trillions of atoms.
If one atom and it were about as big as a model,
how big would your face be?
Well,
about the size of earth.
Still hard to imagine.
Let's try something different.
Look at your little finger.
Imagined that it's tear is as big as the room you're sitting in right now.
Now fill the room with grains of rice.
One rice corn represents one cell of your fingertip.
Now let's zoom in on the rice corn,
and now one cell is as big as the room you're in right now.
Let's fill it with rice again,
this is about the size of a protein,
and now let us feel all the empty spaces between the rice corns with fine grains
of sand.
This is roughly how small atoms are warranted as an asam Maydoff.
Let us just pretend that atoms look like this for a minute.
To make it easier to understand,
an atom consist of three elementary particles,
neutrons,
protons and electrons.
Protons and neutrons bind together and form the atom core held together by the
strong interaction,
one of the four fundamental forces in the universe.
They are made from quarks and held together by glue ons.
Nobody knows exactly how small carbs are.
We think they might literally be points like in geometry,
try to imagine them as being zero dimensional.
We suspect the quarks and electrons are the most fundamental components of
matter in the universe.
Electrons or the ASM call,
they travel at the speed of about 2,200 kilometers per second,
fast enough to get around the earth in just over 18 seconds.
Late quarks,
we think electrons are fundamental particles.
99.999 (999) 999-9999 9% of an atom as volume.
There's just empty space except that it isn't.
What we perceive as entities is actually a space filled by quantum fluctuations.
Fields that have potential energy and build and dissolve spontaneously.
These fluctuations have a fundamental impact on how charged particles interact,
but that's a topic for another video.
How much space to the core and electrons.
Actually Phil,
if you were to subtract all the spaces between the atom cause from the empire
state building,
it would be about as big as a rice corn.
All the atoms of humanity would fit in a teaspoon.
There are extreme objects where states like this actually exist in a neutron
star atom cause our compacted so densely that the mass of three sons fits into
an object only a few kilometers wide.
By the way,
what do atoms look like?
Well,
kind of like this,
electrons are like a wave function and a particle.
At the same time,
we can calculate where an electron might be at any given moment in time.
These clouds of probability called orbitals are where electrons might be with a
certainty of 95% the probability of finding an electron approaches zero the
further we get away from the atom call,
but it actually never is zero,
which means that in theory the electron of an atom could be on the other side of
the universe.
Okay,
wait a second.
These strange thing,
his make up all the master in the universe for many dozens of known animals.
You don't need many dozens of elementary particles,
just three take one proton and one electron,
and you have hydrogen and a proton and a neutron.
You have helium and a few more.
You get carbon,
a few more fluoride,
even more gold and so on.
And every atom of an element is the same.
All hydrogen atoms in the universe,
for example,
are the same.
The hydrogen and your body is exactly the same as the hydrogen and the sun.
Do you feel confused right now?
We certainly do.
Nothing on this scale of the universe makes any sense in our world,
and we've not even begun talking about quantum mechanics or the particle zoo,
which are even stranger.
Our model of atoms has changed a number of times since we first conceived it,
and the current one will certainly not be the last.
So let us support scientists and research and wait for the next wave of mind
boggling new information about this strange world that is the basis for our
existence.